a global treaty for the high seas un
member states trying to agree a deal to
protect fragile ecosystems in
international waters
why is it important and what has
prevented an agreement until now this is
inside story
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the program
i'm laura kyle
countries have tried for years to reach
a global agreement on protecting the
high seas these are areas of the world's
oceans that fall beyond the jurisdiction
of any one nation
each country has exclusive use of its
territorial waters which run up to 370
kilometers from their shorelines
those territorial areas are highlighted
in light blue on this map beyond that in
dark blue are the high seas
international waters that make up most
of our planet's oceans
scientists say existing laws aren't
strong enough to protect those areas
well the high seas are crucial for
supporting marine life as well as
absorbing carbon dioxide and heat caused
by global warming u.n member states are
meeting in new york to try to agree on a
legally binding treaty
they've been negotiating for the past 10
years let's look at why it's so relevant
two-thirds of the world's ocean are
considered international waters that
means all countries have a right to fish
ship and carry out research in them but
only 1.2 percent of these high seas are
protected
this means most of the world's marine
life is exposed to growing threats from
climate change overfishing and shipping
if countries commit to the treaty thirty
percent of the world's oceans would be
considered conservative conservation
areas by 2030
that means that environmental impact
assessments will have to be carried out
before any commercial activities such as
deep sea mining are allowed
well at the un oceans conference in june
secretary general antonio guterres said
some governments were deliberately
stalling progress on a treaty
ergoism
we are dealing with the protection of
biodiversity
in
international waters
but some people still think
that they are powerful enough
to think that international waters
should be theirs
i think it's important to make everybody
understand that international
waters are ours
of all countries
and all peoples in the world
let's bring in our guests now in new
york we have jessica battle senior
expert on global ocean policy at the
world wildlife fund in london danish
mustafa professor of critical geography
at king's college london and also in new
york will mccallum head of oceans at
greenpeace uk well is also head of
greenpeace's delegation to the u.n in
new york very warm welcome to all of you
first i think it's important to address
the fact that we're talking about
half of our planet left currently
unprotected
it's an incredible amount will why is it
so important to change that
it's so important to change the status
quo because
uh with we're seeing that threats to the
ocean are only increasing we're seeing
threats like overfishing like illegal
fishing like deep sea mining all
continuing to increase and very little
action being done to actually protect
the the biodiversity out there on the
oceans and i suppose for people sitting
back on land they might wonder why why
does ocean protection matter for me and
and i'd say well all of us depend on a
healthy ocean to help regulate our
climate to absorb carbon to keep us more
resilient to the impacts of climate
change but also more than three billion
people around the world depend on the
ocean for their primary source of food
so risking that food security through
political inactions simply isn't good
enough and that's why we're here at the
united nations this week campaigning for
a strong treaty to be agreed we'll
certainly talk more about that treaty in
just a moment darn it just before we do
i mean this is a part of the world that
not many of us get to see let's be
honest who does go out there what sort
of activities do we see out on these
high seas
well there are very few uh countries in
the world that actually have the
capability to undertake deep sea mining
it used to be the united states was the
only country until the 1990s that had
the capacity to go out in the high
season and take deep sea mining
uh maybe japan right now has developed
that sort of a capability maybe a couple
of other countries but united states
continues to be the largest player in
the game when it comes to deep-sea
mining
in fact practically the only player that
is up there
so when you're really talking about
regulation of the high seas what you're
really talking about is a handful of
extremely powerful technologically
advanced countries united states being
at the forefront of that
so the question of regulating deep sea
mining is probably
intricately connected to domestic
politics within the united states where
it becomes uh politically feasible for
an administration uh to forego an almost
exclusive capability that they have to
undertake the kind of activity that this
tt is trying to regulate i mean
mozambique or south africa or pakistan
or bangladesh would happily sign the
treaty because they don't have the
capability to go out in the uh
in the high seas and undertake the kind
of mining activities when it comes to
deep sea fisheries again there are a
handful of countries that actually have
the factory
uh boats uh which have that sort of a
range to undertake uh deep sea blue
waters fishing uh chief amongst them
would be again united states canada
uh norway iceland uh japan uh taiwan uh
korea and there may be a few others that
the other participants are probably
mindful of and know of
so again this treaty really is about a
handful of countries that can actually
do something in the high seas
so
obviously there was a there was a
reference in the in the clip that you
ran earlier that there are some
countries which think they are powerful
enough to not worry about the rest of
the world well let's name the powerful
ones right who
don't think that it belongs to the rest
of the world and since they're the only
ones who can get to it i mean jessica
let's just bring you in at this point
because quite quickly we danish has
honed us in from a global treaty to just
a handful of perpetrators so why don't
we just make this a domestic issue and
and hone in on these these few powerful
countries why does it have to involve
the whole whole world
well because the the united nations law
of the sea treaty which is the one under
which this treaty is being negotiated um
actually has 165
parties i think
it's a
it's a pretty uh global treaty and as
you said in your introduction the ohio
state belongs to everyone so we cannot
allow only a few countries to exploit
these vast areas that have so many
benefits for so many people and so many
countries economies as well uh so that
it is very very important that almost
all these countries become if not all
become parties members too this treaty
when it's finalized so that everybody is
covered by it and all activities are
covered by it
um
we
believe
and this is also what uh guterres said
the secretary general of the united
nations in in the clip in the beginning
that the ocean beyond national
jurisdiction is really the large the
last tragedy of the commons you must say
um it really is somewhere where
those who can have been exploiting it to
the benefit for them but really at the
detriment of
all of us and and all of our children's
futures as well so um we even though
it's of course only a few countries so
today have the ability to go out there
and what they do is that they subsidize
for example their high seas fishing
fleets tremendously uh it's very
expensive to to operate on the high seas
um and and they they catch too much fish
they destroy important
habitat a living space for many marine
creatures
and they also catch a lot of important
species in by cats such as iconic
species that we have attribute cultural
or other values to like large whales for
example the turtles
so really yes that it's a
few countries who have activities there
but it's all of ours interest and
responsibility and will we know that
countries like australia new zealand
blocks like the eu are in favor of this
treaty
what about places like america japan are
they on board with it
over the last
round of negotiations that took place in
march we saw that
many if not most countries were in favor
of concluding a treaty the question is
really how strong will that treaty be
and for us as green pieces
environmental campaigners and i'm sure i
share this with others on the call for
us the success of this treaty and its
strengths will be determined on whether
or not it has the power to protect
areas of the high seas can it actually
put areas of the high seas off limits to
some of these destructive industries
we've been mentioning if it can do that
then we'll consider it a a strong treaty
and it remains to be seen how hard the
eu in particular are willing to push for
this we're really worried at the moment
and entering into these negotiations in
quite a tense place wondering how far
will will countries that have previously
been supported be willing to compromise
um because we desperately need that
strong treaty a treaty that can actually
deliver ocean protection the uk
government for example along with many
others has been traveling around the
world campaigning for at least 30
percent of the world's oceans to be
protected by 2030. that's what
scientists say is needed to restore fish
populations keep our oceans more
resilient to climate change now that
target is simply impossible without a
strong treaty we won't get it on that on
on that scale and if we don't agree a
treaty this year it also isn't possible
to protect 30 percent of the world's
oceans by 2030. so the urgency is what
we really need to see at these
negotiations so urgency willingness and
darnish also we we need to know how
we can protect these oceans we're
talking about places that are very
inhospitable that are very inaccessible
how do we actually police these high
seas
again uh just to just to get back uh to
my earlier point
uh
very few countries in the world have the
capability to enforce
right the same countries that have the
capability to go out there and undertake
deep sea mining or subsidize their uh
deep sea uh fishing fleets are the ones
who also have the capability to actually
police those so it's it's it's an
interesting situation that the
perpetrators are also the ones which we
are also asking to police their behavior
so you can get your treaty and if the
united states doesn't sign it it does
it's not worth the paper that it's
written on
uh you can get your i mean it's kind of
like climate change as well right i mean
climate change is a lot more uh
political traction in the european union
even you know to an extent you could
argue in the united states it's in the
public eye but high seas is something
that that's very far away from the
public's consciousness very few people
go out there very few people get excited
about it
and uh
i think that that's that's the sort of
paradoxical problem that you have at
your hands
so
um can do what it wants and you know 165
564 countries sign it in the united
states doesn't sign it
voila you have a treaty but so what i
mean the main country that can actually
do something about it
or is in fact the problem
doesn't sign it so that's end of
discussion that's like saying let's have
a climate change treaty but not have
china or u.s part of it well that
becomes meaningless okay so jessica
what's your response to that i mean
as he was saying you know you can get
everybody signing it but how are we
actually going to police it and will the
u.s be willing to police itself i mean
it's valid points isn't it and what's
the response to that
i don't think we should focus too much
on the united states here because the
united states is actually not a part of
the law of the sea convention and it
still behaves according to the law of
the sea convention i think what is
really important here is
as as we heard that the states who are
parties to this treaty um
they are they are obliged to also make
sure that the flag the vessels that they
flag
um all activities on the high seas are
taking place on from vessels or on
vessels after all but fishing
potentially separate mining shipping of
course cable laying don't forget other
uh
potential and and current uses of the
ocean uh are taking place from from
vessel from boats and these boats have a
flag and it's the is the flag state that
is responsible for the behavior
of these vessels and and as we heard
need to police this um so it really is
this treaty we're hoping can foster
better collaboration between these flag
states
who are signatories to a whole host of
other agreements that they also have to
implement when they're when their
vessels the vessels that they flag uh or
operating on the high seas let's not
forget forget other treaties such as the
conventional migratory species that was
set up to protect
animals that
that migrate across jurisdictions so
from the high seas to national waters
etc
and we have a lot of fish or some fish
species in there turtles etc that is one
of those that they that this uh the the
flag states also have to make sure uh
are followed and what we're hoping with
this treaty is to establish this strong
collaborative mechanism and also um a
sense of um of duty to report what is
going on how are they doing when they're
implementing these treaties so for
example as we were saying if there's a
protected area that has been established
under this treaty that these flag states
are controlling the vessels that they
flag in such a way that they do not
break that law
well
still it's going to run up against some
big powerful interests isn't it let's
look at deep sea mining for example no
license it doesn't happen as yet but exp
exploratory licenses have been released
how much concern does this raise for you
because
people are going to want to explore the
deep sea as resources on land run thin
and as we want to develop renewable
energies we're already finding sources
minerals under the sea that can
contribute to that so there's a
conundrum there in itself
how
how does this argument play out
well quickly on deep sea mining i think
uh
frankly
there is absolutely no need for deepsea
mining the big tech companies the big
car companies who might need these
minerals they're not calling for deep
sea mining they're actually looking at
alternative materials right now deepsea
mining is being pushed forward by a tiny
number of cowboy companies uh who who
desperately want to to find a new
frontier to exploit so
it is a concern for us absolutely that
it's even being talked about seriously
but but um but really i think the the
other obstacles this treaty faces um and
and so how optimistic i am you know no
one said that
deciding that the fate of half of our
planet was going to be a simple task
it's wrought with complexity and
difficulty but it's also this most
enormous opportunity and i have a lot of
hope going into the next two weeks
because the the science is so clear that
when you protect the oceans properly
when you
when you put areas off limits to human
activities when you limit the the more
destructive uh industries out there it
has this remarkable ability to bounce
back to restore life a a sort of scale
that you just don't see on land and that
that vision of hope that that idea that
that that protecting it will will all
reap the rewards of properly protecting
it i hope is what will drive some
governments to really push for the most
ambitious treaty they can i mean well i
love your optimism and i want to share
it but it's been 10 years of
negotiations what makes you think that
this is the year it's going to be agreed
so some very powerful countries in the
room right now are saying this year is
the year we've see we're seeing the eu
come out as a block saying we have to
see a treaty this year we're seeing
other negotiating groups uh like the
pacific small island developing states
like uh like the africa group also
saying this year as a year ultimately
governments don't want to be sending
delegations to new york year in year out
to debate the future of half our planet
they want to they want to see a result
but it is very disappointing not to see
ministers from most countries here that
would really send the signal this is a
political priority so if in the first
few days we're seeing these talks are
are replicating the same cumbersome
bureaucratic processes as before then
absolutely we're going to be writing to
ministers around the world say you have
to get here now you have to come here
and make your voice heard and make
delegations know that this is a
political priority to conclude it isn't
easy of course it's not easy 165
countries agreeing anything isn't easy
but we do believe that
we've put in all of this groundwork for
many years and governments here are
really ready to agree they want this
i'm just wondering well whether you find
that it's already been watered down
because we have a graphic we can show
you um greenpeace and the university of
york released a study in 2019 on how the
oceans could be protected by 2030. now
the areas in orange show the high seas
that are protected now and as we said
earlier it's about one percent and this
is what 30 percent would look like
that's the amount that we're focusing on
they say it is possible to safeguard a
full spectrum of marine life without
disrupting fishing and commercial
activities now that 30 percent it was
brought down from
50 percent danish do you think 30
percent
is never enough is it but is it okay is
it viable is it possible at this stage
of the game
i i'm i'm no technical expert on
fisheries and i i can't really argue
whether 30 or 35 percent or 25 or
what is a good number for that
uh the important
problem i'm trying to and i'm not
against the treaty i think if maturity
is a wonderful thing it happens and i
hope that the optimism is well placed
and it does come through
uh
my view is for example it was just
mentioned by one of the participants and
forgive me i'm not very good with
remembering names uh that
flagged ships are the countries that
flag the ship are responsible for the
behavior of those
vessels
now reality is a vast majority and i i'm
happy to be corrected and if i'm
misinformed on this town vast majority
of the high seas fishing fleets are
actually flagged by liberia and panama
and these small countries out there
which are basically flags of convenience
which basically means that there are i
mean liberia is not going to go out
there and the police a fishing trawler
in the pacific and and and
uh modify its behavior
the other important uh point that has
just been raised is that the law of the
sea is not subscribed to by the united
states uh again well therein is your
answer
uh countries that have the capability
to
actually have high seas fishing trawlers
fishing fleets
the countries that have
deep sea mining may very well be a very
minor part of the picture at the moment
in the future what happens i don't know
those are again problems of these major
countries and i think that
uh
i can i can understand the hawaii
colleagues are hesitant to name names or
to focus on any one country or the other
country but that's not going to change
the reality of the incredible power that
a few
countries have
to create a problem and then to control
the problem
and
without those uh
i mean no one said that
senegal is a problem no one said that
south africa is a problem or that i mean
within the territorial waters they may
very well be but with high seas there's
a very small cast of characters and
unless we focus on those you know pious
declarations that it belongs to all of
us okay i can just see will wants to
join to jump in there just let's let's
jump in
yeah i was just going to say yes yes it
is a small number of countries that are
creating the problems but it is far more
countries who are feeling the impact and
that is why we need these multilateral
processes is to help those countries who
might not have the diplomatic power as a
single entity by creating these
multilateral treaties that that that uh
really deliver a common good so whilst
there might not be some individual
countries creating problems
perhaps the united states won't ratify
this treaty but countries like spain who
have one of the largest high seas
fishing fleets who have been lobbying
the european union for a weaker position
on fisheries they will be bound by it
and they will stick to it the same goes
for france who also have a very large
international tuna fleet they will be
bound by it so there are many countries
that are active on the high seas who
will be bound by this treaty and also
huge trading blocks like the european
union
can
in fact through trade agreements
keep other countries to the the confines
of these treaties to the rules of these
treaties so whether or not a country
ratifies it there are still other
mechanisms by which countries can be
held and jessica's
wanting to join in jump in as well
yes thank you and thank you will for
that
i think also what we have to remember
here is that this treaty is not being
negotiated in isolation there are as
well pointed out there are other
treaties there are also a lot of
agreements that governments have signed
on to because they have understood that
we have a planet that is ailing and that
we need to do something about the way we
treat this planet these are the
sustainable development goals for
example now this is not legally binding
but they are an aspiration of the
international community to make sure
that all states
either reduce the consumption because
they consume too much or are able to
partake in a sustainable development in
in sustainably stewarding the resources
we have to our disposal without further
deteriorating the marine marine and and
the natural environment at large so i
think we must remember that but these
are commitments that these countries
have also signed up to and we have to
hold them accountable which is why we
need to make sure as will was saying
that there's more political will more
political attention to this treaty at
this time
jessica they've got a deadline at the
end of this year to reach an agreement
on this treaty what happens if it's not
reached
if it is not reached they will have to
they will have to have another
negotiation session that is not not
an impossibility but of course during
this time the ocean is continuing to
deteriorate so we do not want to see a
whole slew of more sessions
and we would like them to conclude this
treaty at this time but if there are a
few small issues still to resolve then
yes another session might be needed
but as i said we can't wait uh the ocean
can't wait absolutely okay we will have
to leave it there for the moment we'll
be watching uh the next few days of this
uh convention very closely indeed thanks
very much for taking the time to join us
jessica battle danish mustafa and will
mccallum
and thank you too for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website that's
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
do go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com
aj inside story you can also join the
conversation on twitter we are at aj
inside story from me laura kyle and the
whole team here
[Music]